so I means you remember the first
episode you guys filmed I do yeah yeah
it was the pilot it was March 17th 1998
that's when we shot the pilot and then
it was it was kind of magical how we all
kind of came together and fed off each
others energy and we all have a theater
background so and this feels very much
like theater so we all kind of just made
it happen who are you as an actor then
as comparison to who you are as an actor
now yes I think that's a good question I
think I am a more aware actor if that
makes sense I'm a you know when I was
really really young I was too caught up
in my self-centered narcissistic you
know how their heels I'm getting that
from you yeah this is great for the
viewers to learn no um I was much more
self centered as a young person in the
world and I didn't really have a sense
of different departments that make
something happen so one day just click
that I woke up and I was like wait how
did that camera guy hot in that part of
the craft service coming again how to
hair and makeup like how does it all
happen and that was really interesting
to me and so I learned about direct and
so now I'm a different actor because I'm
more aware of I've had the whole machine
that goes into making a product speaking
of the Machine the writers for the show
are just on fire by the way yeah yeah we
have some of the old renders some new
writers some writers that are old
somebody's that are new that are young
but no it's a it's a wonderful eclectic
group of people that put this together
every week in my opinion these are some
of the best if not better or scripts
than before so how collaborative is that
process now because you know you've
obviously played these greet a process
that's what I say process process that's
okay
process froze to Canadian United States
Oh how how more how much more
collaborative is that because you play
these characters for so long now do you
come to them and say hey this probably
wouldn't do this this is the way yeah
absolutely you know it's more like it's
like a Test match it's like they'll love
us a script the story jokes
whatever it is and we'll work on it and
then we'll come back with suggestions to
them so it's really really collaborative
and thank God because there's I've heard
stories of other shows where it's like
this is your line you stay and you get
out right better it's very friendly it's
very open it's very honest and and
respectful so and I think because of
that process so I process the the end
result is is significantly better when
you talk about openness this show has
tackled tough topics and has had a ton
of social commentary how important was
this show and is this show and in
general pop culture I think the show is
unique in that way I think the show is
one of very few if not the only that has
this kind of thing built into it where
we can comment on what's happening in
the world whether it be pop culture
politics religion sex whatever it is
that a lot of shows other shows don't
have and because of that the show
seemingly has the pulse the finger on
the pulse of what's going on and is
there to comment and about maybe social
issues that aren't everybody can agree
on we put our funny spin on it and then
people can digest it a little easier
like you guys or make a Weinstein jokes
already yeah was that Acco only in
response to him not of the victim of
course yeah but um but yeah I think you
know they're always the writers are
always so clever with coming up with new
ways about how to tackle things in the
moment and if it's really worth it will
reshoot or something that happened that
week if possible yeah if possible it's
not our mo is to tell a great story yeah
but not for not at the expense of a joke
but if we can we do do you look at
what's happening and think about like
pushing the brown G's in terms of sexual
orientation
kind of look at it now it's I mean it's
pretty much commonplace now yeah but you
look and say we were one of the first
shows to really push that boundary and
lead the way yeah yeah yeah I mean you
know being gay it's so funny to say it's
commonplace now it has been for
thousands of years no no I know what you
mean but but I say that and respectful
wave like that you know it's it's it's
always been there and at this show we
were so lucky to kind of bring it into
the forefront of the consciousness of
America and in such a funny way that but
yeah I think now because it's
established that gay people in the world
are just as normal as any other person
in the world that now we can go beyond
that and talk about a deeper issues that
that concern of gay people as well as
straight people and how we all kind of
can live together
having said that have you ever got
stories or fan feedback or something
that actually has hit you or hit the
makers more substantially so it feels
like more than just a television show it
feels more important than that yeah oh
my gosh well the biggest sharing on the
top was Joe Biden devices a free bite
the former Vice President Joe Biden my
deli I said publicly that Will and Grace
has done more to educate America about
gay culture than anything else and I
think things like that just reminds you
of oh there's more going on here than
just a sitcom there is a a reason for
this show to be on television and to be
honest you know people a lot of people
in big cities are like oh I think you
know people have finally accepted gay
people around the world it's like no in
big cities maybe but there is a lot of
work to be done still to educate people
who otherwise don't know better that
that we are to all to be treated equally
and as a race we are human first